[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
hausse des prix le sénat s'empare de la
question
alors que la hausse du panier mensuel
moyen pourrait atteindre les 45 euros
dans les rayons à la rentrée la
commission des affaires économiques à
accélérer les travaux de son groupe de
suivi sur la loi et galim 2
et ce pour démêler le vrai du faux sur
l'origine de l'inflation de certains
biens de consommation
il en ressort que l'essentiel des
augmentations demandées est bien en lien
avec la hausse des coûts de production
il ne semble pas en revanche y avoir de
phénomène massif de hausse suspecte
comme avant c'est parfois dans le débat
public
les travaux du groupe de suivi ont
toutefois mis à jour certaines pratiques
contestables de la part des
distributeurs et des industriels
celle ci pourrait déboucher
prochainement sur des ruptures
d'approvisionnement
certains distributeurs augmenterait les
prix en rayon alors même qu'ils ont
refusé en amont les hausses de tarifs
qui leur était demandé
par ailleurs il gagnerait du temps en
laissant les renégociations s'éterniser
afin de s'approvisionner à l'ancien
tarif moins élevé
les hausses de tarifs pour un même
produit l'eau minérale les glaces les
bières peuvent aller du simple au triple
d'un industriel à l'autre
quant à la loi et galim 2 qui régit les
relations commerciales elle a permis de
sanctuariser les matières agricoles dans
les négociations commerciales
inflationnistes par construction cette
loi doit cependant être adapté à la
période actuelle de renégociation
commerciale permanente estiment les
sénateurs
face à l'envolée des prix la mission est
sceptique sur la politique de chèques du
gouvernement et appelle à des mesures
structurelles fortes favorisant
l'augmentation des heures
supplémentaires et la revalorisation des
salaires
sophie primas présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques juge
préférable une politique ferme de
revalorisation du travail à une
politique de chèques dispendieuse et
éphémère
daniel grémillet président du groupe de
suivi de la loi et galim précise que si
les distributeurs acceptent les hausses
liées aux matières premières agricoles
ces derniers refusent les hausses liées
aux matières premières industrielles
comme l'énergie l'emballage ou le
transport
résultat plus de la moitié du besoin
exprimé par les fournisseurs est ignorée
anne catherine loisier rapporteur de la
loi et galim de souligner qu'en mars le
sénat avait déjà rappelé au gouvernement
son devoir de publier des lignes
directrices en matière de pénalités
logistique
il faut donc désormais qu'ils se
saisissent de ces nouvelles
recommandations en vue des futures
négociations commerciales
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]